national security correspondent jennifer
griffin joins us
yeoman work over there at the pentagon
good evening jen good evening brett fox
news has learned that the withdrawal of
u.s forces from the kabul airport has
already begun
in a race against the clock 37 u.s
military planes took off in the past 24
hours 32 c-17s and 5 c-130s 21 600
people were evacuated among them nearly
9 000 people on civilian aircraft but
the reality of the massive historic
airlift with military planes now landing
and taking off every 45 minutes is
bumping up to the reality that time is
running out on the ground and the u.s
military will soon need to begin packing
when does the u.s military have to begin
making those preps when does that
decision have to be made roughly
speaking you you need at least several
days to get the
the amount of forces and equipment that
we have at the airport to get that
safely and effectively retrograded and
those marines at the u.s embassy the
same american embassy that underwent an
800 million dollar expansion six years
ago they've already withdrawn so you go
to zero
at the at the embassy is that correct
that's correct
the taliban announced publicly after a
secret meeting with cia director william
burns in kabul monday that it would not
extend the deadline for the u.s to
continue evacuations already the taliban
has begun tightening the noose around
the airport stopping afghans and even
those with american passports from
getting to the airport after a
classified briefing by defense secretary
lloyd austin and general mark milley
adam smith the chairman of the house
armed services committee said the
military said it has plans to get
americans out after august 31st if
needed i'm very confident that we'll get
as many as it is possible to get out all
that that's going to be very very
difficult and i was very specific you
need to have a plan to go past the 31st
and they assured me that they do i'm
left confident after leaving that
briefing
here's why it's not a single country
surrounding afghanistan not one has
agreed to allow u.s forces to base there
to allow our intelligence
our drones much less to allow lethal
strikes to keep a lid on al qaeda and
isis and others
there remains a very serious security
threat from isis inside afghanistan that
means if the us wants to operate in
afghanistan after august 31st they'll
need the permission of the taliban brad
jennifer griffin live at the pentagon
jennifer thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else